powerful bathroom stories vol 1 um was
out on the date with this girl she she
you know she's like half mexican half
black oh she cooked an amazing meal dish
guess was cheese a lot of cheese in it
was I don't know what it was I don't
know if no cuz I didn't I know I'm not
lactose intolerant I don't know what it
was in the end Leah thing um didn't
react with my stomach real well this was
at her pleasures like you know when you
always cook for me why don't you come to
my place and not cook so she cooked and
I don't know some of the stuff maybe
been a little bit uncooked so my stomach
I had to eat just to kind of like it's
just like so why immediately I could
hold it anymore I wanted to go home it
but my distance was far away she was all
the way like in north hollywood i'm in
hollywood so it was like okay like and
that's the horrible thing you can't use
a person's bathroom on the bike a second
date or third day go ahead and take you
know at their place you just kind of
like so i thought about like look I
could I was sweating she knew my
conversation wasn't going well my comp
because you know what you're
concentrating on something else is hard
to like have a full conversation she
looked at my buddy's like are you are
you okay and I'm like I don't know like
just sweat just just pouring down my
head and I was like look I gotta use a
bathroom um I tried to turn on all the
pipes all the waters make it look like
you know so it doesn't like a loud noise
coming through then I went in there mind
you doing my thing taking care of
business she had no toilet paper man no
toilet paper she had wendys napkins
stacked up like yellow Wendy's napkins
and it was it was it was it was a
serious situation because I'm like what
do I do when there's only like three
when these napkins you can't wipe your
butt with three Wendy's napkins and it
look like it was half to use so i mean
like happiest me like it was in her
pocketbook or her purse must have been
crumbled up and she kind of like smooth
it out a little bit or flatten it out
but it was it was a traumatic incident
so now mind you don't have enough
Wendy's napkins she's in there wonder
what's going on I'm in there then fully
fully white yet so now I'm in the shower
were trying to take a shower to wash but
it's crazy because she's like are you in
there taking a shower and I'm like no
I'm not even there taking a shower so
mind you I'm in the trying to take a
shower there's that one napkin that i
didn't use now i'm trying to drop my
body off with a wendys napkin and you
know when you get a napkin and you stick
it on wet skin it start falling apart so
now I mind you from big or big Wendy's
napping that was like a tic tac so I'm
trying to get every little area that I
can was really terrible it's the worst
bathroom etiquette story i can tell you
horrible bathroom stories that's one
volume one but i got tons of it and yeah
just stay tuned and listen to the next
one will be view part to join me David
war for the next episode of can I go
viral well I was soon attempt to make a
viral YouTube video